lors du panel politique du vendredi a
sonné nos fidèles collaborateurs sont
présents madeleine de la mort est
sébastien bovet bonsoir
madeleine ne vous avais pas difficultés
de toute évidence à gérer le décalage
horaire après votre périple européen
vous allez encore une fois ce soir merci
d'être là on va donc aborder ce panel
avec bon l'élément le plus restreint de
sur le front politique le drapeau alors
le drapeau l'unifolié qui sera de
nouveau ici dimanche soir évidemment
dans cette optique de réconciliation
avec la proche du jour du souvenir la
pression était forte madeleine sur
towers gouvernement trudeau la pression
était forte parce qu'avais l'échéance du
11 novembre de se retrouver assez
rapidement et les vétérans les anciens
combattants aux l'habitude et c'est une
tradition qui est importante de voir le
drapeau mise en berne pour souligner les
soldats qui sont morts au combat dans
les grandes guerres mais plus récemment
aussi et avec l'année qu'on a eus alexis
avec le rapatriement un peu en
catastrophe deux canadiens de
l'afghanistan avec l'afghanistan qui est
retombé aux mains des talibans ça a été
une année difficile pour les anciens
combattants il y en a eu 20 milles
environ des anciens combattants
canadiens qui ont servi en afghanistan
donc c'était une année particulière en
plus à cause de ça et le gouvernement a
finalement trouvé une voie de passage
est ce que tous les autochtones vont
être contents est ce que toutes les
organisations des premières nations vont
être satisfaits de cet arrangement l'a
probablement pas les autochtones c'est
pas un groupe uni forme les autochtones
n'ont pas vécu nécessairement les
événements et découverte des corps des
enfants autochtones sont les sites des
pensionnats autochtones de la même façon
partout et c'est normal mais j'ai pas vu
non plus de grand tollé à la suite de
l'annoncé du gouvernement trudeau et eu
énormément de consultations au cours des
dernières semaines des derniers mois
donc probablement que le gouvernement a
trouvé une voie de passage et un mot
pour vous dire que les premières nations
ont aussi participé au combat canadiens
il y as parmi les premières nations des
anciens combattants des vétérans donc
pour eux aussi ça peut être important
cette mise en berne du drapeau canadien
sébastien où est le gouvernement a bien
fait de discuter avec les nations
autochtones avec les peuples autochtones
parce qu'il fallait trouver une voie de
passage une voie de compromis c'est un
peu une décision à courte vue d'une
certaine façon pour à justin trudeau au
mois de mai dernier de placer le drapeau
en berne oui on est tous été choqués
évidemment par la découverte des tombes
anonymes dans les pensionnats c'est un
symbole extrêmement fort mais de dire
qu'il allait rehausser le drapeau
seulement quand la réconciliation serait
survenu c'est sûr que la réconciliation
ou des déshérités long processus c'est
ça se ferait pas en cinq mois puis qu'on
arriverait à un moment donné à
l'échéance du 11 novembre puis qu'on
aurait une question à se poser pour nos
anciens combattants ça a été très mal vu
je pense que les anciens combattants ne
puisse pas avoir pour eux le drapeau en
berne donc une décision avec un symbole
fort mois de mai mais avec des
conséquences aussi par la suite c'était
important d'ouvrir la discussion avec
des communautés autochtones avec les
nations autochtones pour trouver une
voie troupes avant de fermer la
parenthèse sur ce dossier madeleine
c'est donc une voie mitoyenne en quelque
sorte que trouve ottawa évidemment après
négociation avec les communautés
autochtones parce qu'on n'a pas accédé à
cette demande de ici un peu partout aux
abords des édifices fédéraux le drapeau
orange de la réconciliation comme
l'avait demandé certains autochtones
notamment la chef national de
l'assemblée des premières nations rosen
archbold qui demandait en fait que le
drapeau autochtone orange pour les
pensionnats autochtones soient ici sur
tous les édifices fiction mais tant et
aussi longtemps qu'on n'aurait pas
retrouvé tous les corps des autochtones
rapatrier chez eux de façon symbolique
ou physique ça ça peut prendre des
années alexis ce que ça démontre aussi
c'est que le leadership de l'assemblée
des premières nations n'est pas le même
qu'il était de chez sap récession
prédécesseur c'est on avait auparavant
un leadership qui était en leadership de
compromis soupiré belgrade mais en même
temps on n'avait pas connu les derniers
mois qu'on a connu avec le deuil
national pratiquement avec la découverte
des corps des enfants autochtones sur le
site des pensionnats indiens donc voyez
vous on est dans une
particulière et sent qu'il ya une voie
de passage et c'est une bonne nouvelle
parce que là les drapeaux vont être
hissé à nouveau et de façon permanente
parce que l'on est en train de se
demander est-ce que c'est seulement le
11 novembre qu'est ce qu'on va faire
avec le 6 décembre le 6 décembre
lorsqu'on rappelle le drame de
polytechnique et lorsque parfois des
personnages importants meurt on met le
drapeau en berne il ya tout un protocole
là dedans il semble qu'il ya une
solution permanente qui soit trouvée et
encore une fois j'en rajoute beaucoup
mais avec le drapeau qu'on doit hisser
en quelque part sur la colline
parlementaire on sait pas encore
exactement où ça va être quand même me
rappelle parce que chez les premières
nations il ya une certaine crainte que
l'on subisse une craie et convives une
crise collectivement au niveau national
et qu'on oublie je me souviens moi
d'avoir couvert lorsque je suis arrivé à
ottawa la crise attawapiskat la crise du
logement s'était c'était une crise
nationale à l'époque et on oublie c'est
facile de retourner à nos anciennes à
nos anciennes façons de faire fuir tout
est beau quand on ne vit pas dans les
communautés autochtones quand on n'est
pas en train de tous les jours aller
chercher de l'eau ailleurs parce qu'on
n'est pas capable de boire l'eau du
robinet quand on n'évite pas les drames
intergénérationnel c'est facile
d'oublier tous donc là il y aura un
drapeau ici quelque part pour se dire
bon il faut que cet écart entre les
autochtones et les non autochtones cette
réconciliation faut qu'elle s'opère au
jeu voire un devoir de mémoire donc
essentiel tout comme cet ajout essentiel
que vous nous amenez madeleine parlons
maintenant d'un autre dossier dont on ne
peut pas absolument pas faire
abstraction l'unilinguisme du patro
d'air canada dénoncé de partout justin
trudeau ya mis son grain de sel
aujourd'hui sébastien et en plus on en a
pris car monsieur legault en fait son
bureau avait averti les gens d'air
canada attention à ce que vous allez
faire si vous maintenez le cap oui c'est
rare que quelqu'un fasse l'unanimité
dans les cercles politiques au québec et
au payer mais monsieur rousseau a fait
l'unanimité en tout cas de la classe
politique locale et provinciale est ici
au québec donc c'est un exploit par
tonne c'est comme si cette controverse
ou ne veut pas s'en aller elle veut pas
aller sous le radar aujourd'hui dans
on a appris que le bureau de françois
legault était intervenu pour essayer de
convaincre monsieur rousseau de
prononcer des mots en français devant la
chambre de commerce de montréal a été
accueilli par un merci mais non merci
semble-t-il justin trudeau trouve c'est
inexplicable il s'en remet à sa ministre
des langues officielles pour voir la
suite des choses donc c'est un peu flou
sur ce qu'il va faire mais la balle
rebondit finalement dans le camp du
conseil d'administration de d'air canada
savoir s'ils vont faire quelque chose ce
qu'ils vont sévir sanctionné à prendre
des engagements à l'endroit de monsieur
au chaud parce que ses administrateurs
sont finalement les patrons de monsieur
rousseau je signale qui a douze membres
du conseil d'administration il y en a
trois qui vient du québec dont monsieur
rousseau deux autres de montréal mais à
part ça il ya des gens de la californie
la nouvelle zélande du royaume uni de
l'ontario de l'alberta est ce qu'ils
vont être sensibilisés à ça peut-être
pas a priori peut-être qu'ils ne sont
pas mais ils sont certainement capables
de lire les journaux et d'avoir des
revues de presse pour leur dire que il
ya une tempête au québec mais ils
viennent de se compliquer la tâche
auprès du gouvernement fédéral aussi
quand on fait du lobbying quand on
demande par exemple des fonds pour se
sortir de la pandémie mieux vaut avoir
une bonne relation avec le gouvernement
fédéral et une bonne relation avec le
gouvernement fédéral ce travail sont une
bonne relation avec le public et ans ça
a été une gaffe de relations publiques
ce qui s'est passé cette semaine ce qui
vient compliquer le lobbying
lorsqu'on cherche à avoir des faveurs du
gouvernement c'est comme si ça prendrait
plus qu'un engagement à améliorer son
français vous avez noté dans son
communiqué me réjouis et redis je
m'engage à améliorer mon français on
comprend qu'il part de loin puisqu'elle
améliorer ce sera pas si difficile que
difficile que ça mais pourquoi ne
prendrait-il pas un engagement de
d'apprendre le français de suivre des
cours et pourquoi pas de s'engager a
prononcé un discours un moment donné
devant la chambre de commerce ou
n'importe quel autre chambre de commerce
avec du français de oui mais je pense
que toute cette affaire là on n'aurait
pas créé un si grand tollé si air canada
n'avait pas la réputation d'être le
mauvais élève en termes de français on a
vu les plaintes se multiplier au cours
des 50 dernières années auprès du
commissaire aux langues officielles qui
avaient de la difficulté à se demander
mais comment on va faire en sorte qu'air
canada devienne un bon joueur se
préoccupent sincèrement des de la langue
française du bilinguisme du bilinguisme
nationale air canada répondait à ça que
vu le nombre de passagers qui empruntent
les transporteurs le transporteur d'air
canada c'est un peu normal qu'ils aient
quelques dizaines quelques centaines de
plaintes donc c'était leurs excuses et
eller leur façon de répondre à ça mais
en même temps il ya une réputation qui
s'est forgé année après année après
année commissaires après commissaire et
la la la nouvelle mouture de la loi sur
les langues officielles du mois le
projet de loi vise à donner plus de
pouvoirs ou comme sert aux langues
officielles entre autres pour pouvoir
avoir
plus de mordant lorsque il essaie de
mettre au pas des compagnies ou des
angles plus tôt des institutions qu'ils
se conformeraient pas à la loi entre
madame petit pâté le fait un suivi sur
ce dossier justin trudeau semblait très
heureux de la chose maintenant petit
tour d'horizon rapide comme 26 monsieur
trudeau et le go ils ont eu leur
participation à tout ça alors ces
conventions par vous sébastien françois
legault comment vous évaluez ça en dit
melle sa performance à glasgow françois
legault il est plusieurs costumes et
qu'il porte dans sa garde-robe selon le
moment il a souvent été capitaine québec
pour défendre l'identité québécoise et
là c'était françois legault commis
voyageur c'est à dire le vendeur du
québec le démarcheur en chef du québec
qui voulaient vendre l'électricité autre
que le québec comme batterie de la
mecque du nord est un cochon slogan je
te paie ironique parce que il s'est fait
mettre un bâton dans les roues avec la
décision du maire de refuser un projet
d'hydro-québec on verra où ça nous mène
par la suite il y aura une contestation
et tout cela donc mais ça démontre la
difficulté qu'il peut avoir françois
legault à vendre son grand projet de
faire du québec la batterie nord
américaine cela étant dit il veut vendre
le québec qu'il veut investir dans
l'énergie verte dans l'électrification
des transports mais il est pendant les
grands discours de réduire à un ennemi
degrés celsius l'augmentation des
températures à travers le monde dans les
grands discours de
réduire encore plus les gaz à effet de
serre lui maintient ce ciel qui est plus
ferme que la cible du pays et du canada
il est plus au ras des pâquerettes je
dirais c'est comme ça à vouloir faire
des investissements dans les
technologies vertes plutôt que dans les
grands discours donc c'est peut-être son
rayon d'action remarquer pour une
province et par pays le québec donc
c'est peut-être à ça mais c'est très
sain ça fait très affaire quant à
monsieur le groupe prend la parole dans
ce genre d'événement c'est sa zone de
confort ça c'est sûr et certain
madeleine messieurs guilbaud et trudeau
un qu'en penser j'ai l'impression que
moi je mettrais un habit de scouts je
voudrais être d'autres toujours là pour
aider donc on fait notre part on veut
faire preuve de leadership
la réputation du canada et
était à refaire d'une certaine façon
lorsque justin trudeau est arrivé au
pouvoir il a dit le canada est de retour
le canada est de retour ça voulait par
exemple dire le canada est de retour
dans les missions de paix le canada vous
un siège au conseil de sécurité de l'onu
et là dessus le bilan est plutôt mince
pour le conseil le siège au conseil des
associés raté mais il restait quand même
la question des changements climatiques
et le canada n'est pas parvenue encore à
réduire cécile mais il a des mesures a
montré entre autres la taxe sur le
carbone entre autres des promesses
électorales sur le plafonnement des
émissions du secteur pétrolier et gazier
et ça a été dit et je pense que ça a été
en partie remarqué mais l'épreuve reste
encore à faire tour à tour ce que vous
suivrez la semaine prochaine sébastien
bank of conférence annuelle du
commissaire de l'upac la semaine
prochaine j'utilise beaucoup de
questions à lui poser madeleine caucus
libéral le 10 ans n'a pas eu encore
depuis les élections pas de caucus
officiel encore donc j'ai l'impression
qu'il ya des députés qui ont très très
hâte de rencontrer leurs collègues enfin
distille merci beaucoup et madeleine et
ses bas ses ventes cette semaine
bourquin
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit